[音楽]
皆さんの中で
フェラーリ載ってらっしゃる方どのぐらい
いらっしゃいますか
フェラーリないですかねあの
私の周りにもちょっとなかなかいなかった
んですけどもでどんな人がフェラーリに
乗るのかなと思ったんですがあるところで
見つかりまして私の大学時代の友人なん
ですけれども
突然ポンポンポンと出世しまして
収入が倍増してですねで何をやったかと
いうと
フェラーリを買ったわけですね
でしかし彼は非常に忙しい人なので
ほとんど乗る暇がないそういうわけでこの
フェラーリは
残念ながら
こういうふうに
駐車場でカバーをかぶったままになってい
たとでこれではまあ意味がないとまあ思う
わけですがまあ彼はあのカバーをかぶって
いても美しいとか強がりを言ってました
けれどもしかし
結局これを手放してしまったんですね
でここでちょっと考えてみたいのはどうし
て
駐車場でカバーをかぶったままだと
意味がないのかということです
これすぐ思い浮かぶのは
車っていうのはそれに乗ってどこか遠くに
行くためのものでその観点からすればまあ
駐車場でカバーをかぶったままだと意味が
ないということになりますよね
車があれば
電車が通ってないような遠い
自然の中にもいけるあるいは
ミシュランの町を
訪れるということもできる
そんな風に車っていうのは
我々と何か新しい体験と
繋げてくれる間にあるような
狭間にあるようなものだというふうに考え
られると思うんですね
車っていうのがこういわば通路になって
それを通って私たちは見知らな体験へと
繋がっていくことができるそういう媒介の
役割を果たすのが
車じゃないか
でそう考えると
まあもしかしたら車だけじゃなくて
いろんなものについて同じことが言えるん
じゃないか
まあ例を挙げていますけども
例えば
椅子ですね
椅子っていうのは我々普通まあ椅子があれ
ばまあ単にそこでもう
完結した独立したそれだけで成り立って
いる出来事というかねまあそういうものが
そこにあるとしか考えないわけですけど今
ここには椅子はないですがもし仮にここに
椅子があったとしたら私にとってはそこに
座るという可能性が開かれるわけですよね
でそういうわけで
椅子があるとそこに新しい可能性が開ける
私とその新しい
体験とつなげてくれてるのがイスだとで
普通あの道路の上にはあの
椅子っていうのはないですけど
道路の上に一層置けばそこに座るという
可能性が
開かれるわけですね
そんな風に私と座るということを
媒介してくれてるのが椅子だっていう考え
方ができるんじゃないかと思うんです
あるいは他の例で
本っていうのもありますね
本というのは小さな
物体に過ぎませんけどただの紙がね束ね
られた小さな物体ですがしかしそれを
持っていけば
電車の中でも旅先でもどこでも新しい世界
が開けてくる
例えば
電車の中で本を開けばそこで
例えば中世の貴族たちの華やかな世界に
入っていくことができるあるいは
未来の宇宙での大冒険に入っていくことが
できるあるいは
数学の非常に抽象的だけども美しい世界に
入っていくとか何千年もついている哲学の
世界に入っていくとかそういうことが言い
ながらにしてできるのが
本というものの果たしている
機能だと思うんですね
そしてさらにまあ例えば
スーツというのを買えばそれまで行くこと
のできなかったフォーマルな場に行くこと
もできたりするわけですよね
学生さんであればまあ
就職活動とかあるいは冠婚葬祭とかですね
要するに今までできなかったことをできる
ようにしてくれてるそういう媒介を果たし
ているのが
例えばスーツというのもそうだと
あるいはその航空券ですね
航空券を買えばミシュランの土地に行ける
私はこういうグリーンランドに行ってみ
たいなと思ってるんだけども
グリーンランドに行きたいなと思っても今
ここにいるだけではダメですねで
航空券を買うとそうすると航空券でもって
そのグリーンランドを体験するということ
をつながってくるわけですあるいはインド
に行きたいとかあるいはアフリカに行き
たいとかいずれも
同じことが言えますよね
そういう風に
物っていうのは
我々と何か新しい体験との間にあってで
それを繋げるような役割を果たしている
ものがそれだけで行き止まりじゃないん
ですね
そこから先へと繋げてくれる媒介になって
るっていう風に考えられるんじゃない
でしょうか
でここから
交換ということについて話をしていきたい
と思うんですけど
ものはある特定の
体験にしか我々をつなげてくれない例えば
食べ物をたくさん持っているという人も
それは食べることしかできないわけですね
衣服をたくさん持っててもそれは着ること
しかできない
しかしここで交換というのを挟むと
食べ物を持ってる人は衣服と交換すれば着
るっていう可能性も開かれてくる
あるいは
逆も言えますね
衣服を持っている人は食べるという方にも
いけるようになるそういうふうに交換と
いうのを介していろんなところに行ける
ようになると
でこれがまあこの交換っていうのは非常に
意味のあることなのでそこから
人類の歴史の中で経済というものがここ
まで大きく
発展してきたんだと思うんですねその交換
に
特化したものっていうのはお金ですよね
貨幣です
お金というのはお金で買えるものだったら
何とでも
取り替える取り替えるというか交換する
ことができる何でも交換できるわけですね
でそういうわけでお金というものは我々に
色々な
体験をまあつなげてくれるような役割を
果たしてくれる
お金というものを返して我々はいろんな
ところに行けるわけですよね
でそういうわけでまあお金が
ドバッとあったらまあ我々興奮したりする
かもしれませんけどそれは別にその
紙ぺらに
興奮してるわけじゃないわけですねお金
っていうのは物としては単なる紙ペラです
その神プラに興奮してんじゃなくてそこに
無数の可能性を見てるわけですねあれとも
あれもできるこれもできるこれもできると
言ってみればそこで
我々が興奮しているのは
紙ペアじゃなくて
媒介の塊に
興奮しているとそんな風に言えるかもしれ
ないと思うんですね
でそれがそういう媒介ということについて
お話してきましたけどその媒介っていうの
がもしかしたらこれからの時代の一つの
なんて
言いましょうかね新しい数千になってくる
んじゃないかっていう風にも私は考えてい
ます
これまでお話してきたのは物っていうのは
手に価値があるということじゃなくてもの
が何かに媒介してくるから価値があ
るっていう話でした
最近あの学生さんたちに自動車欲しいです
かっていう風に聞くといや別に自動車
なんかあの
買いたくないですと言うんですねなんでと
いうといやカシェアリングがありますから
ともし自動車が必要だったらカーシェアで
借りればいいと
でこれ非常に
合理的な考え方だと思うんですね
先ほど最初に見たように
駐車場でカバーを被ってたら車っていうの
は意味がないですよねだからその間他の人
が使ってくれたら
車というものの意味がもっと
十分に実現できるわけです
そういうわけで
監視シェアリングっていうのはその所有と
いうものから
むしろ媒介というものつまり
物を通して何か体験を実現するっていう方
へともう考えを動かして考えをシフトし
てるんじゃないかと思うんですで他にも
シェアリングエコノミーというのは色々と
展開していると思いますけど
実感の自転車をシェアするとかあるいは
シェアハウスであるとかこういうのは
いずれもその所有から
媒介へこう時代が映ってきてるような
そんな印象を私は持っています
あるいはまあ現代を
象徴するようなものとしてインターネッ
トっていうのはあると思いますが
インターネットっていうのはそれを通して
世界中のあらゆる
情報にアクセスできる
つまりあらゆる世界中の情報への行って
みれば窓みたいな
役割を果たしてるわけですよね
でそういう形で我々をいろいろな情報
世界中の様々な情報へと媒介してくれてる
のが
インターネットじゃないかというふうに
思いますあるいはまあSNSですね私が
何かツイートすればそれを別の人がリ
ツイートするとそれまた別の人はリ
ツイートするつまりそうやってどんどん
どんどん
媒介していくわけですねお互いにでそこに
まさにそのSNSの
本質の一つがあると思うんですけどそう
いうようなことが今
盛んになっているとすればそれもまた何て
言うんでしょう何か固定的な行き止まり
じゃなくてむしろ媒介っていうところに
時代の
空気が映ってるようなそういう省庁と
言えるんじゃないかなというふうに思い
ます
ここまでつながるという話どんどん
つながってくっていう話を中心にしてき
ましたが実は媒介ということはつながる
だけじゃなくて
切るということも非常に重要なんですね
それをこれからお話したいと思います
そう言ってるのは近代日本の哲学者である
田辺肇という人なんですでこの田辺始
めって人は共闘学科の哲学者でいわゆる
西田幾多郎
沖になった方多いと思いますが
彼の後継者ですねで彼が
媒介というのは切ることによってつなぐ
ことだというふうに言ってるんですこれ
ちょっと一見ちょっと聞くと矛盾して
聞こえるおかしなことに聞こえるんだけど
実はそんなにおかしくないですね
非常に自然なことで大事なことを言ってる
と思うんです
例えば私の腕の骨っていうのはこの真ん中
のところで切れてますよね
でもしこの腕の骨が全部つながってるとし
たら私の動きが非常に限定されてもう非常
に困難変な動きしかできないと思うんです
ねでこれ真ん中で切れていてしかも関節で
つながってるから私にはいろんな自由な
動きができるね
多様な動きとそれがしかもまとまっている
統一性というのが
多様性と統一性が同時に実現されている
ようなそういうことが可能になっている
わけですよね
でこういう風に
切れてるものが繋がるときにそこに非常に
自由度のある新しい可能性が生まれてくる
ということがあると思うんです
繋がったままだとあまり自由度がなくてね
多様性もないですね
これ我々の体についてもそうです我々の体
はお互いにキレてますしかしこの223脚
のように体がつながってるとしたらどう
でしょうか
非常に
動きにくいですね
自由度が低いこれ2人どころか10人とか
20人とか30人とかの人が
ずらっとこうついてたらもう
全く
動きが取れないですねこれ30人の人が体
が切れていてそれぞれ分業していろいろと
したらこの今回のスタッフもそうですけど
も
みんなで分業していろんなことをやったら
こういうことが実現できるわけですね
はるかに効率的に動けるわけです
あるいは我々の意識ですね
我々の意識もお互いに切れてます
あの
テレパシーのようなものがあってお互いの
意識がねお互いにわかったらいいなと思う
こともあるかもしれないけど
実際にそれをやることを想像してみたら
非常に
煩わしいかもしれませんね
他人の意識がどんどん入ってくるわけです
ね
そして自分の意識もダダ漏れになっちゃう
これは非常にやりにくいことだろうと思い
ます
むしろ意識が切れていてで言いたいことを
伝えたいことは
言葉という形に圧縮してそれをお互いに
やり取りするこういう方がはるかに情報
効率が高いですよね
そういうわけでこの切れてるということ
つまりそれは間があるということですけど
我々人間同士の間にも間狭間があるわけ
ですがこの間があるということが
むしろ
新しく自由な仕方で繋がるための一つの
可能性につながってるじゃないかその
チャンスなんじゃないかというふうに
言えるんじゃないかと思うんです
私はそのいろんな研究者と共同研究して
ますけれどもそういった例えば私自身は
哲学を専門としていますが
例えば神経科学者であるとか人工知能の
研究者であるとかあるいはロボット研究者
ですねこういった
共同研究していますで
哲学とロボット研究とかだともう全く違う
ものに思えるんですがこれ違うからこそ
非常に面白いんですね
非常に面白い
相互作用があってですね
全く違う知識全く違うスキルを持っている
からこそそういう人たちが出会うときに
そこに極めて想像的なアクリエイティブな
可能性が生まれてくるそれに私は非常に
興奮しているとでこれをます進めていき
たいと思っていて私たちがやっている人間
地のAI研究
研究教育センターというのも
そういう可能性を追求していきたいと思っ
ているところなんですね
まとめに入りたいと思います
私がお話ししてきたのは
媒介ということがもしかしたらこれからの
時代あるいはそのすでに今もですね非常に
重要な
意味を持ってるんじゃないかっていうこと
ですそれは売買というのは切ることによっ
てつなぐその消えているものがつながると
いうことです
でこれをもしかしたらこれからの時代の
新しい理念のようなものになりうるかなと
いうふうに考えていてこの
違いとか分断まあ私と皆さんも違いますし
皆さんもお互いに違うと思うんですけれど
もこのお互いの違いこれは
狭間という風に言ってもいいし
切れている分断というふうに言ってもいい
し
こういう切れ目や間というものがもしかし
たら
単にネガティブなものではなくて
非常に大きなチャンスになってるんじゃ
ないかお
互いの違いこれはもう常にありますね
同じでありようがないしかしその違いが
見つかった時にそれは単にネガティブじゃ
なくて
違うからこそここに何か面白い
新しい
創造的なつながりが生まれるかもしれない
そういうふうに考えられると思うんです
そういうわけでまあこの
創造的な媒介を実現しうる間狭間っていう
ものが
我々の間に開かれていてこういうものに
着目していくといろいろ面白いことが
起こってくるんじゃないかなというふうに
私は考えていますこれが今日皆さんにお
話したかった私のアイデアですどうも
ありがとうございました
[拍手]